bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi
siamo su which un videogame che mi state
consigliando da mesi e che ho fatto
soltanto per levarmelo dalle balle
perchè continuate a consigliarlo così
siamo a posto allora non è da di che
cosa sia
ho sentito delle recensioni dicendo che
è un gioco strano a tema horror sempre
penso perché non ho capito bene comunque
ho visto un paio di screenshot ho capito
soltanto che tutto in bianco e nero e
basta non ci ho capito niente comunque
lo faccio così siete contenti che
succede in tanto qua sul muro ci sono
scritti i comandi allora il tasto
sinistro prendo e va bene
apre i cassetti fantastico tipo come se
fosse casa mia tranquillamente dov'è la
nutella non c'è
proviamo fa 6 cassetti di sul tasto
destro se ci si accovaccia questo visto
prima ma cos'è una chiave massimo ok ho
preso una chiave qua ho aperto tutto che
bravo ma c'è un cuore perché non siamo
ok effetto è un bagno a un'altra chiave
no è caduta con theo bos marcatissima
non devi fare così per spaccarlo devi
tirare una bozza invece niente va beh
ora c'è gabinetto
ok non mi do da fare e state tranquilli
vado via
vado vado sopra perché qua non c'è
niente da fare
ho trovato una chiave siamo già un punto
fantastico ma anche se era abbastanza
facile da trovare un po stretta come
casa 1 2 3 cos'è questo odio lander c'è
la porta dello studente ragazzi si è
chiusa chiusa due chiusa una chiave
cielo qualcosa servirà una che i aperto
presto 7 cassetti che è sto schifo vuoto
fantastico la nutella della nutella non
c'è traccia di cos'è questo omino più
chiaro è uguale porta diverso da chiave
più due uomini no aspettate io non ho
capito la nomino più chiave uguale porta
ma la porta non è uguale a una chiave
più due omini capito perfettamente devo
risolvere l'equazione non lo so cos'è
sta roba
non ha senso a una porta e c'è una
portanza i propri la finestra o cos'è
questo un'altra chiave 2 questa prima
seconda porta ragazzi poi qualcuno me lo
spiega questa perché non ho capito il
senso la porta a chiave 2 penso che sia
una montatura
sì perché se a salve se girata mi chiama
statua lei bella cosa mi serve sexy lady
mela da restivo la chiave mise lo
sorpassa indicando a
chi c'è c'è un'altra equazione ho
provato a risolvere quella di prima non
ci sono riuscito chiave uguale lander
diviso amore chiaro quale slider diviso
amore non ho capito che cazzo è piano è
c'era la privacy mai sentita no di
questa si gira ragazzi inquietante ma
statua senza testa senza il cuore che si
gira
senti io ho aperto in cassetti prima per
vedere se c'era la nutella ma non c'era
oddio sai calma non apro niente più
chiudo la porta più importa liberta non
si chiude sentita la chiave che c'hai la
chiave che hai in mano non ti sto
guardando gli stai tranquilla non sono
pervertito ho bisogno della chiave che
c'hai
[ __ ] cosa è successo è sparita ok
ragazzi io questo non l'ho capita c'è
una statua con una chiave che mi indica
le equazioni scritte sul muro non si sa
perché ci sono 64 insensate sul muro e
poi sparisce
sto facendo addosso ragazzino senso
cos'è questo cos'è è un ok mi metto a
fare l'idraulico
perfetto allora vado a smontare il tubo
di sotto
ok sparita non c'è proprio vado a
smontare la roba per la chiave 18
fantastico bella ragazza mi piaceva sei
qui allora allora senti devo buttare la
mattina e caduta anna chiave nel davanti
allo small telo rimonto basta che non mi
rompi ti giuro non faccio niente devo
smontare soltanto la parte 18 prendo la
chiave telo rimonto te lo faccio un
nuovo vado dai che a 5 minuti
ok chiave 3
ok caffè non post dopo apro la porta e
terrori molto st te lo giuro vado di
sopra si stai tranquillo
perfetto salgo le scale al contrario
grandissimo ok ce l'abbiamo fatta senza
e convenienza quella rimasta di sotto
fosse probabilmente forse non sa neanche
salire le scale speriamo chiave 3
sventando si apre si apre ok o che boa
un'altra chiave cos'è
ok questa la chiave dolosa ok capiamoci
chiariamoci subito non c'è un'altra
chiave io cos'è quello c'è scritta una
roba leggo sono solo i crediti di chi ha
creato il gioco non mi sembra il momento
adatto per leggerli sentirti dopo a
sarre dietro non pensare male se ti
sfioro dietro ma devo andare ok perfetto
non mi guardare non mi guardare così
ok ok
apro la porta dello slang ragazzi in
ogni gioco che faccio ci deve essere per
forza woodlander però meglio se
preferisco lo svenderà questa qui
ragazzi cè un cesso di nuovo
ok senti ho aperto la porta mi fai
uscire perché non c'è niente c'è un
lavandino
c'è un cesso possa almeno avere un po di
privacy mentre faccio i cazzi miei
perché che cazzo è questa c'è una testa
nel allora ho trovato la tua testa nel
cesso da voi non la posso non riesco a
prenderla però ragazzi
senti non so chi te l'ha messa io non
sono stato io vado sotto a ok per vai tu
apprende non lo metti giuro non l'ho
messa io voglio stare ora sta prendendo
davvero ma veramente
ma cos'è
sarà adesso se la monta tipo transform o
di sera montata la testa tranqui questo
è il senso di montarsi la testa ragazzi
ok che fai qua apri a port bravissima
prima porta perché voglio uscire quando
mi piace suo posto cosa fai
apri apri no guardi a ci ho provato
prima a capire ma non si capiva adesso
poi vede neanche tu e guarda c'è scritto
un omino più chiave uguale a porta
diverso da una chiave più due mini non
so che cosa vuol dire non ho capito che
cos'è il terno stai calmissimo oddio
oddio oddio questo odio mi violenta ma
che cazzo fa
metti via quell'affare che mai scambiato
per un oddio che mai scambiato per un
cotechino
oddio ma che cazzo sto facendo è
perfetto grazie molto gentile senti non
ho io ti ho aiutato trova la testa
sono stato bravo a dio che violenza ma
perché è basta
ma che sarò mai male la madonna visto
così tanto sul culo aiuta ancora basse
[Musica]
ma basta hai finito
grazie per mamma mia che violenza in
questo gioco e violenza in questo gioco
ragazzi brass e uscì brava così si
trattano gli ospiti bravissima wii two
weeks un cazzo perfetto ok ragazzi ho
riavviato soltanto perché mi avete detto
nei commenti mentre avete l'impatto che
ci sono due finali 1 s aprirà la porta
dello slider un'altra pista porta quando
il cuore mi sembra aver capito ora
aspettate un attimo che prova a
definirlo un secondo avesse the stati
bravissimi me l'avete detto nei commenti
non mi ricordo che che me l'ha detto ma
qualcuno è stato poi vabbè lo ringrazio
va bene ci sono due finali avete detto
che c'è un'altra chiave nascosta che è
quella del cuore che nella stanza di
quella dove ho trovato quella dello
slider vicino alla porta non l'ho vista
prima scusatemi buono mi ricordo più
la chiave qui ok perfetto lo rifaccio
alla veloce tanto dovrei riuscire a
farlo abbastanza velocemente una volta
che sole cose chiave 26 ott
perfetto grazie sì non guardo neanche se
[ __ ]
scusami ma ci stava e non puoi trattare
così gli ospiti e barbera che non sei
altro guardatelo tour equazione stanza
va bene avete detto che parimenti c'è un
de finali una buona uno cattivo io ho
fatto evidentemente quello cattivo
presumo ok quella chiave è che cazzo
prima non si spuntata così però ok ci
sono anche andato addosso perfetto
chiave numero 3 siamo veramente già di
nuovo alla fine come veloce quando sei
le cose ah si mi dimentico che ogni
volta ragazzi mimetico di dirlo se lo
volete scaricare sempre in descrizione
comunque tutti i giochi che faccio mi
metto sempre descrizione riporta numero
mi avete detto vicino alla porta ti ho
infatti ci avete ragione presa chiave
col cuore e ma qua c'è sempre chi a
vicolo dove andare però io vado da
domandato a sei qui senti io vado di
sotto che mi hanno consigliato che c'è
qua perché adesso capisco perché il
quale le manca ha quindi posso prendere
o il cuore ho la testa e sembrano tutte
e due ma vabè sperimentiamo solo questo
non vuole proseguire oltre
ok perfetto il cuore esteso tipo ii
stendini potevi metterlo almeno fuori
che sgocciolava perbene o fa brutto
tempo non so non me lo prende però sa se
lo mette lei forse sì milady prima le
signore perfetto
voglio vedere come sono impianto sono
curioso con delicatezza delicatezza si
bra non è esattamente così
dopo l'addio che schifo ibride che la
forma che c'è sul petto non è a forma di
certo è a forma di cuore ma ma non di
cuore vero è semplicemente il cuore è
quello disegnato come c'è stato lì
dentro non lo so va bene torno di sopra
penso che sia di mogli intento ad aprire
la porta questa volta poi riuscire a me
però ok la fai niente non ci fa come
prima di nuovo
edi è sempre quello stesso problema è
omino più chiaro è uguale porta diverso
da chiave più domini non so cosa vuol
dire senti vedi di star calma che già
prima mi hai fatto no no no dai è che
stai calma però dio santo ma non si
aspettano aspetta si sta dio che schifo
piano mettimi no ma che schifo dai
ragazzi ma perché fate ste cose
sì va bene bra bravissima ok c'è ma
perché tanta violenza ma pasta una dio
sa ancora ultra ok perfetto grazie sei
contenta se per dopo la pacchia
ho vinto va bè ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto il video lasciato mi
piace io ho trovato una qualcosa di
osceno e niente se lasciato mi piace
anche sulla pagina di facebook e che
trovate sempre nella descrizione di ogni
mio video il download che lo trascina
iscrizione ma ho lasciato un commento e
niente ci vediamo prossimo video bella
ragazzi